hey guys how's it going welcome to
another episode of ij likes i was trying
to clean for you
my idea of cleaning is basically just
pushing everything to corners and
strategically placing myself in front of
the mess so you guys won't even know
that i'm a hoarder or a slob or a pig or
all of the above multiple choice a b c d
all of the above
what is happening right now
anyways i d likes i like things
you guys like things and i talk about
what i've liked in the past week so this
week there were some amazing videos that
i came across uh first we're gonna start
with
let me pull it up this video is titled
it wasn't me
and don't forget all these challenges we
got into it
the best part is this right now
currently has almost 5 million views who
is jay harris first of all who are you
okay well i was hoping to find some sort
of news about this video to maybe figure
out who actually made the poo poo so far
there isn't anything so let's move on to
the next video which this is actually a
legit awesome video i'm a huge fan of
the cup song i'm a huge fan of mumford
and sons so my friend brent morgan took
these two things and put them together
[Music]
this next video just completely just
creeped me out it's the closed mouth
singer also well she's four million
views i can't is unbelievable
[Music]
i don't even want to try it i'll try it
again well i don't want to do it oh my
god
i feel like i'm going to throw up
screw it next up science technology and
gaming i'm so excited because this
wednesday depending upon when i'm
actually posting this video doesn't
really matter because wednesday is
wednesday the new call of duty ghost
multiplayer will be revealed so we're
gonna get to see some some stuff i don't
really know what we're gonna get to see
but i'll be there so i'll be tweeting
and instagraming and vining and
tumblring and google plusing google
plussing i don't think they've really
figured out the name of that yet you
guys have been asking me what my iphone
case is and i've had this for quite a
while but this is the olloclip iphone
case it's did i show this to you already
i don't remember well i'm gonna show it
to you anyway even if i did you flip
this up and you put this
little lens on and it'll turn it into
wide angle fisheye
and a macro lens and i know i've
definitely showed you guys this before
but i don't think that i showed you the
actual case so this is pretty sweet also
has a little bottom of which i i don't
see anywhere it just clips right on and
it'll turn it into like a little tripod
so you can use it as a tripod last up we
have our fashion style in beauty and i
want to show you guys this this is a
nars like body glow
something i don't even know what is this
called it smells like hawaii i will mix
it with some moisturizer and it gives
you a nice bronzed sun-kissed glow even
when you don't even leave your house
ever also i gotta hold on a second these
are so sweet so i got these today just
in time to go to the beach they are
called i actually don't really know how
to pronounce it i am a terrible person
s-o-l-u-dos
solidas salados saul all i know is
they're awesome so if you know how to
spell you don't need to know how to
pronounce look at them and you know what
it says on the bottom of the summer
thank you guys for watching i love you i
will see you in my next video if there's
something that you would like me to
cover here on ig likes let me know
because you guys actually haven't been
sending me stuff lately so hashtag ij
likes send it to me and you may see your
submission here in a future episode a
solution sold you though so you know so
hold your doors
[Music]
just be quiet